es ist ein gefährlicher agenten krimi
mitten im ukraine krieg mit einem mord
im direkten umfeld putins und jetzt mit
bildern der angeblichen mörderin
der russische geheimdienst hat diese
bilder gemacht diese frau soll eine
mörderin sein ukrainerin sie soll immer
software regiment gekämpft haben bilder
von der straße von ihr in ihrem auto 24
stunden überwachung ja und jetzt soll
sie mittlerweile in estland sein diese
angebliche natalia und zwar nachdem sie
angeblich dieses attentat verübt haben
soll anschlag auf dari adelina eine
putin bekannten ideologien eine
fanatische russische propagandisten
ernst sie ist die tochter des radikalen
putin einflüsterer ist alexander dugin
sie stirbt bei diesem attentat ihn sein
wir hier gerade im bild und nun seit
russland wütend die ukraine war es ja
das sorgt für heftige diskussionen
darüber sprechen wir mit unserem bild
reporter paul ronzheimer wieder in der
ukraine mitten in kiew also wer hat
dieses attentat begangen wer hat diese
autobombe gezündet es soll diese natalia
sein sagt der kreml gewissermaßen sagt
der russische geheimdienst
du hast sehr große zweifel um das
vorsichtig zu sagen glaubst du daran
dass es aber doch aus der ukraine kommen
könnte diese tat
kein man muss eines vorweg ganz klar
sagen wir ich wissen es nicht es gibt
keine klaren belege keine beweise es
gibt nur überlegungen spekulation und es
gibt diese
angeblichen bilder vom russischen
geheimdienst fsb jetzt muss man sagen
aufgrund der erfahrungen der vergangenen
jahre hat der fsb bei diesen fällen zur
ganz ganz großen anteil immer gelogen
gerade wenn es um ausländische fälle
ging und es sind doch ein paar dinge
sehr auffällig erstens wie kann es sein
dass nach so kurzer zeit nicht so großer
bestimmtheit schon feststehen soll wer
das ganze getan hat zweitens wenn man
diese person überwacht hat dann muss ja
verdächtig gewesen sein also warum hat
man sie dann nicht gestoppt und drittens
passt das natürlich alles so sehr in das
bild dass russland zu diesem fall
verbreiten will dass man doch sehr sehr
nachdenklich werden muss und zu der
theorie kommen muss dass da irgendetwas
eigentlich nicht stimmen kann denn das
passt zu perfekten das bild das nur
minuten nach dem attentat verbreitet
werden soll und ja hier in der ukraine
weist man das von sich alle
berater von selensky alle
präsidentenberater sagen dass sie mit
diesem mord nichts zu tun haben dass sie
nicht in diesen mord verwickelt sind und
dass das absurd sei was dort aus
russland kommt dass mit der polka die
opodo ja gesprochen einer der
wichtigsten der engsten berater von der
präsident sie lenski mit ihm hast du ja
über diese autobombe gesprochen dass und
schauen was er dazu gesagt hat
es gibt eine neue eskalationsstufe
zwischen russland der ukraine und
estland russland behauptet eine
ukrainische agentin habe die tochter von
du ihn angegriffen sie sagen dass sie
bereits so genannte beweise haben was
antworten sie darauf
die ukraine ist sicherlich nicht in den
mord von frau dugena verwickelt es macht
in vielerlei hinsicht keinen sinn für
die ukraine ist die familie von dougan
kein objekt das aktiv dem krieg
zugeschrieben werden kann sie sind
einfach elemente des allgemeinen
hysterisch und propaganda systems
russland sich an gezielten
terroristischen aktionen zu beteiligen
indem man jemanden auf dem territorium
des russen eliminiert ist nicht der weg
der ukraine die ukraine führt einen
befreiungskrieg zweitens ist es absurd
zu sagen dass eine sabotage gruppe der
ukraine im am besten geschützten
addition of distrikt rund um moskau
arbeiten kann dies wirft die frage nach
der arbeitsweise der russischen
sicherheitsdienste auf drittens wird nur
der teil der russischen politik vom tod
von florina profitieren der sich für
mobilisierung weitere eskalation
radikalisierung und die fähigkeit zum
einsatz von waffenarten einsetzt die
durch verschiedene konventionen verboten
sind es ist sehr wichtig zu verstehen
was russland in sachen propaganda tod
russland versucht das widerzuspiegeln
was sie selbst in diesem krieg
demonstrieren sie führen einen
terroristischen krieg und die welt sieht
es live russland wird beschuldigt
friedliche nachbarschaften zu beschießen
kriegsgefangene zu demütigen und andere
technologien einzusetzen die als
terroristisch bezeichnet werden können
zb das kernkraftwerk publisher um die
negativen ruf der russen zu mindern
versuchen sie spiegel technologien
einzusetzen und beschuldigen die ukraine
des einsatzes terroristischer techniken
die ukraine betrachtet diesen krieg als
verteidigungskrieg und neigt nicht dazu
terroristische technologien einzusetzen
der hauptstadt und in diesen minuten
nationalhelden dort während russlands
ganz schnell erklärungen und gründe für
ihren tod gefunden hat und man paul in
kiew jetzt auch befürchtet das ist
vergeltung geben wird denn russland hat
jetzt ganz klar ja sich eine neue
strategie zurechtgelegt kann die auch
die hauptstadt kann die auch hier
betreffend fürchtet man dass es dort
jetzt wieder zu anschlägen kommen könnte
und die bilder patricia die wir jetzt
zeigen die bedeutet vor allem eines wie
wichtig russland wie wichtig der kreml
jetzt plötzlich die tochter von queen
macht man muss ja eines ganz klar sagen
sie war vorher einem speziellen publikum
bekannt sie war eine von vielen
propagandist innen aber sicherlich nicht
die wichtigste aber jetzt wenn man das
ausmaß sieht auf der live übertragung
der äußerung der demonstration die es
dazu in moskau gibt und gab dann muss
man sagen versucht man sie jetzt zu
diesem hoch zu stilisieren eben zu sagen
dass sie eine unglaublich wichtige
person ist und das wiederum bedeutet
hier natürlich höchste alarmbereitschaft
in die tatsache dass man das ganze in
propaganda fernsehen jetzt gerade auch
live überträgt bedeutet dass man
möglicherweise etwas vorbereiten will
und sagen will weil das in moskau auf
unseren straßen passiert ist wo man der
ukraine die schuld gibt greift man hier
an und da gibt es ganz klare warnungen
von amerikanischen geheimdienst und wir
erinnern uns vor dem 24 februar lag
dieser geheimdienst als einziger fast
auf der welt richtig mit der tatsache
dass russland das ganze land angreifen
würde und jetzt sagt genau und dieser
geheimdienst patrick sehr das ist zu
angriffen auf regierungsgebäude im
ganzen land kommen könnte und auch eben
zivilisten überall betroffen werden
jetzt muss man einmal einordnen hier
hinter mir sieht es ja einigermaßen
normal aus denn das ist ihren kiew gab
es länger keine angriffe mehr im osten
und süden trug der krieg immer weiter da
gibt es weiterhin jeden tag angriffe
aber
hier wurde bislang seit beginn des
krieges und weder das parlament noch der
präsidentenpalast oder auch nicht weit
von hier entfernt das bürgermeisterhaus
da wo witali klitschko residiert wurden
nicht angegriffen und jetzt sowohl der
amerikanische geheimdienst als auch
siemens gibt das regierungsgebäude
getroffen werden könnten und das wäre
dann gerade was das angeht eine neue
eskalation die der einigermaßen normal
aus sagst du stehst aber da ja vor einer
masse von panzern das sind immer noch
die russischen die kaputten die
erbeuteten panzer die die ukraine dort
aufgestellt haben auch um jahr zu
motivieren in diesem so schwierigen
kriegstagen nach sechs monaten krieg und
zu mobilisieren auch weiterhin im
eigenen land danke bild reporter paul
ronzheimer in die hauptstadt nach kiew
ja nach diesem offenbar politischen mord
die in der kreml jetzt politisch umso
mehr als vorwand für möglicherweise neue
angriffe auch auf die kriegs hauptstadt
kiew nutzen möchte
[Musik]